[Music]
my
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
see what's going on all right they
should be able to hear me fine too
let's get it
you said somebody said you started too
early
let's go
what
are you going to get your kids get your
kids
get your kids cinnamon
he said the iop stream is live
yeah the glitch is still in y'all
what glitch is it
all right i cannot switch my primary
weapon yeah i couldn't do that the other
day i thought i just didn't have a
primary weapon
like i low-key didn't like yeah because
whatever your primary is this beta is
you staying with the plotter
i don't even know how to shoot that gun
that i was using man
yeah i wasn't ready for that
they came over the cliff with the
grenades
[Music]
this is fine you know you know how we
get there yeah
this is my joy right here
hold on hold on
total control
oh god
i need
to the left to the left
i love how these sites come in man
let's go
let's go oh i got a grapple hook let's
go
oh you got the gravel mm-hmm
i have no clue how to use it right
bumper okay
oh let's do it over there let's get him
let's get him take b y'all robber
brothers
yeah
oh my god there's like 18 people there
it's
yeah i feel very lost about my pro
secondary
[Applause]
because like my secondary is a decent
mid-range weapon and i can't use it at
all
yo it is more buttery like
to the left to the right
oh dude trying to put oh he's trying to
pull up here
he goes he's trying to run out
he tried to wrap you up
yeah wait i know you're working on
something
[Music]
there you go there you go go ahead reg
one three three three seven
contested
grapple hook
behind you cog behind you oh i got it
yup we got this game
for this
that that was ricocheting man
yeah yeah
let's go
miles oh
he says cross play on pc yeah i think
it's crosstalk
hold up
oh it's
man i want to wait for i'ma wait for it
i'ma wait for it what you waiting for
you sitting there camping you can't
figure i'm waiting for this br i'm
waiting for this vr
it's it's it's done man no i know i was
waiting for the br
oh you were real you got it yeah i got
to be on all right where we going
they got a warthog behind me
[Music]
get the job
we don't take out the driver we take out
the gunner because he's useless about
the gutter exactly
i said what you doing i see you over
here
you over to me
i need help i need reinforcements
b is real b is real right now i'm trying
to clear it out
what you hiding from
double kill
total
[Music]
yeah i can't switch either this just
you get stuck you get stuck with
something you can like no ammo
yep
get some [ __ ] called heatwave
yeah
i think he isn't that the one you can
switch the shotgun
all right i'm gonna go to a
big be a big plural
all right c c is a rat i only got a
shotgun i can't switch to the secondary
is
how does the stream look guys
let's go
i mean fred just told me what's going on
shout out to fred
get that beat back there we go
don't count all right
oh come on
all right so the train looks good all
right that's all that matters
off get out of here
oh they too
they fight
they want that
they get here
oh my god yeah they can hear you
no doubt
i guess we doing guns up in this [ __ ]
oh they got me
they got me with that um that spike gun
the one that shoots spikes at you yeah i
know what you talking about
oh you got a hammer
you gonna shoot me from behind between
go reveal yourself we got to take that a
and b man
we're going for b right now
yeah they are eight oh
yeah a hard body karate right there oh
get off that
get off there
oh man i couldn't find that where he was
i'm just so you it's so weird not having
a second
they gotta fix this glitch
like one would think it was it was like
this last week too one would think
they'd have that fixed like
yo they want a heavy
i need my primary but i don't like
having the br not being able to use the
ar as a secondary i know
also when the news is
cast that it's a wreath okay
they don't just let it rock like i like
destiny or something
you know where all three get the cap
yeah they just they spawn
you can fix the weapon switch but it's
in the menu windows central has
workaround steps so apparently there is
a fix for it for right now
yeah but that's definitely it is you
yeah they need to get that fixed
they got to get that fixed you can't be
switching whatever you need
i'm boyfriend you go there's a heat wave
right there
i don't even know how to use this
bastard
we got to find out
long range type joint
is this the one that bounces
it might reflect i can't remember
let's go right there
i don't like big maps like i've always
hated big maps i feel like there's too
many line of sights i get shot from
head's up
and it doesn't help that i don't have
access
we lost
yeah we were dominating
what we were until that last in a triple
cap and it was went downhill from there
that's what it is though
does my stream look choppy to you a
little bit here
no you look good
on my laptop
yeah you fine
only time i ever really got kills is
when i had that uh vr man i killed like
five people in a row with that br like
it's just
crazy i run out of ammo so fast because
of this glitch
somebody said window essentially about
the glitch already
yeah apparently
you can fix the window switch but it's
in the menu
so what you got to do in the menu did
you say i don't know he didn't say
anything about it
hey tag one of us in the uh the article
on twitter please so i can read it
well tag me
weird glitch that they find before lunch
me before this
ninja house is she working it's her
background
that's what's up
okay i had no problem with a big match
yeah i'm the same way okay as long as
there's a lot of players i'm good
uh
it's very small i can't front
i like how they do that trials of osiris
thing yeah
[Music]
you know they got if they they just sell
a bunch of these remotes for the
pre-starts
they're going to kill it with monitors
take their stuff and protect our stuff
your friend is due by like are we
protecting or we're defending
are we doing both
oh this is capture
capture the flag baby you know how we do
the vehicle oh god they already have
i wonder if i can
clamp on
all right all right let's go let's go
let's go let's go
we got their flag we got them
did you see the cheat with the flag and
the grappling hook yeah it's pretty good
somebody put it on twitter when you
could grab the flag and throw that [ __ ]
back on
you can roof it you can roof
i don't know where the grappling hook is
drop me off by the flag oh
jesus
why everybody else can get more vehicles
i don't know why that dude got out you
know what i'm gonna stay on defense
y'all doing uh
reminder this is exciting oh man oh my
god
what is that
[Music]
defense that's what's up
oh you could detach these dreams
oh god
next one oh get him
go ahead touch it if you want
i'm dead
in case you didn't notice i'm dead yeah
that's his new type of fire get up get
from around here
none shall pass
see i don't mind kept playing capture
the flag like this
i feel like it man jon snow
he was down with the night watch looking
over the wall
yeah this guy coming in the vehicle oh
hey gotta go with the vehicle well
that's y'all he come in the vehicle
where was he shooting me from yeah yeah
yeah yeah got him
got him
get off that get off that door or get
you oh they got there
they sent it they paid what they got
they almost got it they look good
got them their names
[Music]
is
[Music]
i only got one more left
all right let's go in there man let's do
this destiny
right there he's dead
wow i didn't think he could
it could be outside
yeah
i'm coming i'm coming i'm coming
man
there's a guy walking around with the
turret
what did he shoot like
yeah you could you could take it
dismantle it and walk with it
oh someone said all these trees remember
when you walk through them
yeah you complain about trees now
[Music]
like a vehicle
oh okay like a drop okay there you go
yeah yeah yeah oh we go to the left to
the left
we're gonna stack this up
right here
i'm gonna draw this wall over here by
the um defense unless y'all want this
for offense i wanna wait for
it seems like it seems like we've
abandoned our stuff man we're going
straight for their [ __ ] now
yeah y'all going all offense
oh they coming they're coming
oh they with a warhawk
on defense
yeah they got it so they go we got to
take theirs down we got to take theirs
now
somebody shot this right there but they
still in the spot
don't mind if i do
oh this thing is so fat slow
where is my buddy
he was over here a second ago
you gotta be more aggressive than that
the whole team is over there trying to
take that flag
that's hilarious
yo the detaching work and though
controller things yeah so many glitches
they gotta fix these glitches there's a
sniper here well that's what's the beta
definitely not working
damn it
i dropped it
yeah we uh
oh
somebody ready to spot somebody you
think they slick i got him i got him
let me bring it down he returned their
flag he was slick how i see him oh he
must have been invisible
i didn't see him on the
radar why the flag ain't going back oh
you got to stay in there okay there you
go you got to stay in a circle
oh you got 25 points for that
all right i'm coming
man
i just
normally i would switch to a br or
something but i'm not even trying to
pick anything up because i only have one
weapon
oh here they come are
they try to get me sad they try to get
me you messed up you messed up fam you
messed up
let's see what you try to do all right
that was funny i got a br
send
i'll start heading your direction
i'm being shot by something
get ready i think it's coming around the
corner
oh here they go
let's go got him right on on the ridge
all right come on
there you go buddy hey what about guys
it's funny doing it they got it alone
though like you've been wrong
like somebody really went into your
house and broke it
oh
let me try to go off
all right said where are you
dead
i'm pulling back i'm outnumbered
yeah there's a bunch of them broken ring
[Music]
all right to the left to the left
there's a bunch to the left
i'm almost out of ammo man all right
right what you saying get him he got all
right
let's go to the right
all right
try to cut through the trees
it ain't looking good
from
[Music]
texting the wrong number meds yeah you
out what what other addict you got your
your your playlist man
oh [ __ ] you still good come come to me
come to me come to me come to me
go back to the base come to me come to
me escort
it
i got crushed
they brought it back they put it back
not yet not yet uh what if our guy is in
the streets into the street
damn it dude this this ammo [ __ ] is
ridiculous because i don't have a
secondary
there's just too many people to be able
to kill in one little soul man
don't yes i'm coming in man i'm going
calm down
stop beeping in your heart
go go go go stop playing
go
go here's the chair go keep driving keep
driving go go what are you doing what
are you doing
go go go go go go
stop playing
go go
kill him
kill him kill that dude return the flag
return
return and return return it
return
i'm killing him
it won't score
come on
him what is he doing
just stay there just stay there he's
taking the flag away
he's taking a flag what is he doing he
don't know the rules
oh
oh you oh no it's not
okay i'm an idiot i'm an idiot i'm an
idiot it's my fault it's not his he was
going the right way i wasn't a touchdown
touchdown friday night got a five dollar
stream drive from raven blade i'm pissed
at work listening to youtube i'm hearing
gunfire in cogs voice feeling very
jealous now i'm going to stop working
head home now look man don't let halo
let you lose your job man
got a two dollar super chat for writing
blade add a grenade then shoot and shoot
yeah that was lit that was like that
might have to go on tick tock that might
have to go
up
so still who who grabbed your body jose
i grew up i brought it home i didn't
bring it home that time
i brought it home and i got out and i
just started playing people i was just
protecting the vehicle like the whole
route so it was a contest at the end
because
what both people had the flag and then
where our flag is that's not where you
drop it you gotta drop it upstairs
that's where we had the issue we were
thinking we had to drop so that's why
attic was yelling at the dude like what
are you doing what to do was going to
the right place yeah i just didn't know
because i've you've never got the flag
that
no i know that's what's up
so you know it's not like you got to go
to where the the uh flag spawns that you
had
actual meds i i didn't see this man like
you're gonna have to call me don't text
me man don't text me you have to call me
and no i'm not selling that 1080 t i
already gave that whole pc to my brother
why are you putting why are you putting
the business out on the stream though i
mean
he was asking was he selling it and i
told him no
but that was for the tax bill that was
fun look man
we got a two dollar super chat from
right in blaine how long is this flight
for i think a couple more hours
yeah i think it ended like five
got 114 in here watching though
yeah riley said you wish solving king of
there yeah they work well solve is
working
king might be sleep at this time it came
out at a weird time for friday but
there's more time slots got half the
lords in here man you got 50 50.
exactly got sinister lord
look
look the trees the trees
the trees don't move but i don't expect
that from halo it's about the
multiplayer it's about the multiplayer
it's not about how the game looks just
about the most player because it looks
so good in the between the bushes look
man
look man this don't look like a pixar
game all right
i'll put you on that one normally you'll
be willing but that's what i'm with you
nah we ain't about that christopher you
you bugging
you right really you bugging christopher
hardy you're bugging me
ain't no bush complaining
you're bugging christopher i don't
appreciate that attitude
where's your magnum it won't let me use
it
all right this is the um straight up
this straight murder death kill yeah
unfortunately oh
yo
hold up come here get your murder off
pull the trigger
[Music]
like this
[Music]
how are you out here hiding with me look
okay let's see what you're doing
oh
no you got to fix your call you have
both the primary and the secondary all
right uh i will try to see exactly
what's up with that after this game
maybe wait what he said no
you cannot switch to your secondary
weapon so whatever your primary is
you start
so they fix this
apparently it's a loan
working on it
um
i got two left
how come every time i'm on the bridge
someone don't like me
get out of that
he got a ghost oh that's ah
they ran me down that's crazy
this is my stuff where is someone man i
gotta pick someone up i need some help
i need some milk delilah said change
your control to default then adjust them
i had to say
someone gets in the machine gun
i'll do it i can't do it
yeah
somebody just floating across the air
booster
nice
all day in the jeeps setting
set
restorative oh yeah i fixed it right
away yeah yeah it did just just restore
the default that's all yeah
oh i feel so much better
i'm alive
all right i'm restoring
make
yeah go over there man go over there
she's the real goat in this game man
exactly she's out here she's the real
mvp she out here giving that premium
content
y'all got the riposte oh yeah we back
home
shout out to below with the two dollars
super chat i don't care the lord's day
shout out to the lords i appreciate it
you know appreciate you
oh god oh god oh god oh god
buddy
where are you guys buddy
this isn't a 60 frame stream
i don't know how this stuff works
what's up hto
i don't know how this stuff works man
he said you ain't doing halo justice
where the 60 frames right that's where
you go he coming at you i don't know
you you
all i know man
is this halo
television 60 frames for us yeah
i don't know he might be saying the
stream's at 60 frames i might need a few
yeah
yeah i'm probably not 60 that's what it
is
your stream's not at 60.
your stream looking like vc or xbox i'm
just joking
is it pixelated any
or is it just something
you're definitely moving in 30 though
on your stream
there's probably a setting this was like
you just gotta am i moving at 30 or just
in general everything's moving at 30.
hold on let me kill this boy off the
torah
yeah get off the driver
it's youtube don't blame them
yeah that's youtube man
you said you're a tech guy
look man
oh this dude what weapon is that
is warzone coming back to halo it's not
at launch but i wouldn't be surprised in
a year maybe two they they introduce
warzone back to halo
[Music]
he was definitely lacking there was no
denying that he was definitely lacking
they're just running around
looking for somebody running
you got to respect the hustle that's a
free kill you gotta
oh there's two of them
i got one of them
a two dollar super chat from raiden
blight oh my god i'm trying to limit
tomorrow's workload
look man
don't lose your job over halo it's
coming out in december
make make my fifth look at him
[Laughter]
uh
yeah they have pretty good quality i
might end the stream after this game
just to see if i can fix that 30 frame
thing
yeah
that's always going to stick on two
zones there's not much time left
rebooting what the hell is this man yeah
what's that reboot
something over here is rebooting
oh no oh i caught somebody outside i
heard somebody slacking over here
something's rebooting in a moment
in a minute
what happened
we only up by four man we only up by
four
boy doing them dirty on the freeway
yo you got a better better look more
graceful you cross that street
[Laughter]
ascend to the left to the left as people
are coming
i'm gonna be out right now
24.92 sticks together
there's one feels tight
oh he got me grenades got me 96.95
yeah man um find a teammate stay in the
head
yeah
what i'll do for you guys
all
right
because they got that vehicle in our
spawn yeah they're shooting
i i gotta try to run away but i couldn't
crazy
nice
he said he's so nice
[Laughter]
yo
the way he said nice is so aggressive
it's it's it's like he was about it's
like he was planning his victory speech
that's your personal way i was talking
no you he was like nice
that's a
closer all right let me go ahead